sechster dezember geldautomaten
sprengung in mönchengladbach auch der
sechste dezember schwerte aus sprengung
eines geldautomaten dann der vierte
dezember geldautomat in hainburg
gesprengt auch am vierten geldautomat in
köln/bonn gesprengt und dann haben wir
hier noch dem dritten dezember mainz
bretzenheim sprengung eines
geldautomaten auf dem uni-campus das
sind nur einige polizeimeldungen aus den
vergangenen tagen denn jede nacht fliegt
irgendwo in deutschland ein geldautomat
in die luft und dahinter stecken fast
immer kriminelle clans aus dem ausland
sebastian bringe nico nelken stefan
sander und benjamin sack berichten
sparkasse bamberg mitten in der nacht
dieses überwachungsvideo zeigt genau wie
abgebrüht die geldautomaten sprenger
vorgehen sie leiten gas in den automaten
bringen ihn zur explosion dann räumen
sie in leer fast jede nacht wird
irgendwo in deutschland ein geldautomat
gesprengt im vergangenen jahr 414 mal
fast 20 prozent mehr taten als im
vorjahr schadenshöhe 17,1 millionen euro
beute dazu millionenschäden an geräten
und gebäuden
[Musik]
in ratingen reist eine explosion
anwohner aus dem schlaf gerade haben
gangster versucht einen geldautomaten zu
sprengen anwohnerin sapina wird
augenzeugen des raubzugs hält die szenen
mit ihrem handy fest
schockiert darüber
wohnung passiert was explodiert oder so
dann war ich halt erstmal im bett und
mit anrufen und dann hab ich gerade noch
mal gewählt von bienen und dann gab es
schon die zweite explosion
dann habe ich das fenster geöffnet und
konnte dann sehen dass da ein schwarzer
5er bmw stand und drei männer diät und
war mit schwarzen pullis und
die haben die deutsche bank ausgeräumt
explosionen in der nachbarschaft
inzwischen fast trauriger alltag
regionaler brennpunkt der geldautomaten
sprengungen ist nordrhein-westfalen
131 mal schlugen die täter dort bislang
in diesem jahr zu bild reporter
sebastian prengel begibt sich auf
spurensuche
der zu drei tatorten der vergangenen
wochen
bad honnef in der nacht zu donnerstag 2
uhr 10 eine explosion zerreißt die
stille der beschaulichen kleinstadt bei
köln
[Musik]
hier in bad honnef sind anwohner gegen 2
uhr in der nacht von einer lauten
detonation aus dem schlaf gerissen
worden und was wir hier sehen ist einmal
der geldautomat gewesen da ist nicht
mehr viel übrig der ist komplett
weggesprengt von hat das jetzt hier mit
spanplatten notdürftig verkleidet und
wenn wir uns einmal das dach anschauen
dann sehen wir diese immense
zerstörungsgrad ist alles deformiert und
wie man uns gesagt hat sind teilweise
zehn kilo schwere metallteile noch gut
und gerne 30 meter in diese richtung
geflogen auch die glasfront der
anliegenden bäckerei ist zerstört die
fensterscheiben sind von schrapnell
getroffen wurden auch oben in der
wohnung darüber sind fensterscheiben
durch die druckwelle kaputt gegangen das
jetzt alles erneuert worden und was
anwohner noch beobachten konnten ist wie
maskierte männer in ein auto gesprungen
sind und flüchteten den standort hier
haben die täter offenbar ganz bewusst
gewählt denn bis zur autobahn 3 sind es
nur wenige meter nach dem was wir
bislang wissen sind mehrere täter in
einem vw golf so ist unser kenntnisstand
ein dunkler vw golf über eine größere
straße in unmittelbarer nähe geflüchtet
und zwar in richtung autobahn 3
und die wir haben dann ein
entsprechendes spurenbild und wissen
dass jedenfalls beute gemacht wurde im
umfang von mehreren tausend euro
mönchengladbach sechster dezember zwei
uhr 15 augenzeugen filmen mit dem handy
diese dreisten gangster in der vorster
straße das wohnhaus gegenüber wird von
einer heftigen detonation erschüttert
die dinger aufgesprengt wahrscheinlich
richtig freuen
diese sparkasse in mönchengladbach ist
vom geldautomaten springern regelrecht
verwüstet worden wir sehen hier auch
tage nach der detonation ist die filiale
immer noch geschlossen und es wird auch
noch einige zeit dauern bis das chaos
beseitigt ist und bisher überhaupt
wieder geöffnet werden kann wir haben
man muss fast sagen es grenzt an ein
wunder dass hier niemand verletzt wurde
dann anwohner berichten uns von szenen
wie in einem film und wenn wir uns die
fassade einmal anschauen dann sehen wie
es ist wirklich erschreckend wie heftig
die worte dieser detonation gewesen ist
es muss auch ein statiker kommen der
überprüft hat auf dieses gebäude
überhaupt noch bewohnbar ist
neues sechsundzwanzigster november drei
uhr nachts verbrannte geldscheine auf
der straße zeugen von einer mega
explosion die die geldautomaten sprenger
hier verursacht haben in neuss schlugen
die täter mitten in der innenstadt zu
und zwar mit so viel bumms dass die
farbpatronen in den geldkassetten
geplatzt sind und die scheine danach
unbrauchbar waren etliche 20 euro noten
haben außerdem feuer gefangen und lagen
verkohlte auf der straße herum und den
täter an denen gelang in einem dunklen
mercedes mit gestohlenen kennzeichen die
flucht
die spur führt in zwei dritteln aller
fälle von nordrhein westfalen in die
nahegelegene niederlande dort agieren
banden mit hunderten gangstern meist
junge männer mit marokkanischen wurzeln
bild reporter sebastian bringe beim
september bei einem zugriff in venlo
dabei konnte vollzug vermelden um vier
uhr nachts war es in lünen in nrw zu
einer geldautomaten sprengung gekommen
die täter flohen über die grenze der
zugriff erfolgte nun anderthalb stunden
später am frühen morgen haben gangster
in lünen einen geldautomaten gesprengt
dann jagten sie mit einem 320 ps golf
über die autobahn richtung holland der
wagen steht jetzt immer noch hier hinter
mir er ist von spezialisten untersucht
wurden auf sprengstoff auf beute auf
hinweise zu den tätern ein mann ist
verhaftet worden und zwei weitere
gangster sind immer noch auf der flucht
vergangenen donnerstag wird einer der
köpfe niederländischer geldautomaten
sprenger tarik b an die deutsche polizei
ausgeliefert der mann mit marokkanischen
wurzeln soll für über 15 geldautomaten
sprengungen in deutschland
verantwortlich sein und sogar ein
ausbildungscamp für springer in utrecht
betrieben haben
das geschäft der automaten springer ist
ein verdrängungswettbewerb da die
niederländer ihre geldautomaten immer
besser schützen kommen die verbrecher zu
uns nach deutschland
denn auch heute nacht können die
gangster wieder irgendwo zu schlagen
[Musik]
und dieses massenverbrechen wollen wir
jetzt weiter analysieren mit unserem
chefreporter frank schneider und frank
scheulen vom lka düsseldorf denn dort
jagt die soko heat seit vielen jahren
geldautomaten sprenger
ja genau zwar seit dem jahr 2015 werden
die täter hier gejagt weil
nordrhein-westfalen besonders betroffen
ist wir haben es gerade gehört die täter
wurden häufig aus holland nordrhein
westfalen liegt sofort an grenzen und
herrollen ist hier neben mir schon was
ist das besondere an den strukturen an
diesen klaren strukturen dieser
tätergruppierung und wie gehen die vor
also wir gehen von tätergruppierungen
aus den niederlanden aus also
niederländische staatsangehörige mit
marokkanischem migrationshintergrund
gruppierungen die im großraum rotterdam
amsterdam utrecht sich aufhalten
ungefähr 350 bis 500 personen in diesen
gruppierungen und das ist das reservoir
wo genau diese geldautomaten sprenger
ihren nachwuchs rekrutieren jetzt
stichwort sprengstoff früher war es ja
gas das war immer das thema es wurde gas
eingeleitet jetzt ins mittlerweile
teilweise auch sprengstoff was macht es
gerade für anwohner von geldautomaten
ist so extrem gefährlich wie hat sich
die situation da verändert also die
sprengungen mit einem gas luft gemisch
waren schon immer sehr gefährlich jetzt
wird sprengstoff benutzt weil natürlich
auch die geldinstitute inzwischen ihre
geldautomaten sicherer gemacht haben die
aussteller haben sichere technik
eingebaut das haben die täter
wahrgenommen und dann entsprechend ihren
modus operandi angepasst und benutzen
jetzt sprengstoff das hat natürlich
weitaus größere folgen bei einer
explosion in den umliegenden häusern in
den straßen und nicht zuletzt auch mit
bei den tätern das ist also höchst
gefährlich jetzt heißt er die soko nicht
umsonst sieht es geht ja um einen
sozusagen heißen reifen und in anlehnung
an den hollywood film an spektakuläre
fluchten was ist bei den fluchten so
außergewöhnlich und wie gehen die täter
davor also die täter reisen den
niederlanden an irgendwann in der nacht
sprengen innerhalb von zwei bis drei
minuten solchen automaten glauben das
bargeld auf wenn sie den automat haben
öffnen können und dann beginnt die
flucht phase und die täter benutzten
hoch motorische fahrzeuge ein sehr
aggressives fluchtverhalten wird an den
tag gelegt teilweise mit über 250
stundenkilometern werden hier die
tatorte verlassen quer durch nordrhein
westfalen gefahren in richtung deutsche
niederländische grenze um dann natürlich
wieder in die niederlande zu
verschwinden jetzt gab es aber auch mal
taten wo dann motorroller benutzt wurden
warum das also die täter haben natürlich
auch gemerkt dass die polizei ein
gewisses fahndungs schema an den tag
legt und mit dieser methode wollte man
diese forderung unterlaufen das heißt
die täter kommen mit einem lieferwagen
rollen dann zwei motorroller rausfahren
damit zum tatort wieder schnell drei
ecken weiter in den lieferwagen oder
aber in angemietete garage um dann den
fahndungsdruck in ruhe hinter
geschlossenen garagentor abzuwarten um
dann ganz entspannt wieder die
niederlande zu reisen das sind bisher
die erfolge der polizei es gibt jedoch
einige spektakuläre festnahme haben es
auch gerade gesehen was können sie da
momentan vorweisen und was ist ihre
strategie also wir haben in den letzten
jahren knapp 140 tatverdächtige
festnehmen können wir haben eine gute
und enge zusammenarbeit mit den
niederländischen behörden so das
europäische haftbefehle von der
staatsanwaltschaft düsseldorf ein fall
natürlich dann auch in den niederlanden
vollstreckt werden können unsere
kollegen assistieren dann dabei also
hier kommt es auf das gute miteinander
der deutschen niederländischen
kriminalbeamten an das problem ist
natürlich wir haben tatzeiten mitten in
der nacht wir haben sehr kurzer
handlungs zeiten und das ist für uns
schwierig vorher zu bestimmen wo findet
der nächste angriff auf einen
geldautomaten stadt wir haben alleine in
nordrhein westfalen knapp 10.000
geldautomaten die grenze nach den
niederlanden die existiert zwar noch die
staatsgrenze ist aber normalerweise
nicht mehr sichtbar und von daher haben
die täter ungezählte möglichkeiten
wieder zurück zu flüchten vielen dank
herr scheuen man sieht daran die polizei
tut sehr viel aber es ist auch nicht
ganz einfach die erfolge sind da doch
die täter agieren weiter und man muss
abwarten ob man möglicherweise überhaupt
jemand schafft diese tätergruppierung
komplett zu stoppen
ja vielen dank frank jetzt haben wir
also ganz viel
die gangster gehört aber uns uns
interessiert natürlich wie genau diese
gangster vorgehen und wie man eigentlich
so einen automaten geknackt bekommt
deswegen haben wir uns einmal genau so
einen automaten ins studio geholt und
dazu ein mann der weiß wie man so einen
automaten knackt wolfgang stabe es bei
uns guten abend waffentechniker und ich
habe gelesen ein mann über den man sagt
es gibt nichts was er nicht geknackt und
gesprengt bekommt klangschön dankeschön
für die einführung vielen dank ja also
relativ einfach ich habe mittel die ich
in jedem baumarkt kaufen können als
erstes natürlich akkuschrauber mit dem
vernünftigen bohrer bei euch hier noch
einmal ganz groß wo genau würde denn
reimer da wo das geld raus kommt bei der
ag festgestellt haben eine öffnung drin
und da sitzt man also an und da brauche
ich dann praktisch ein loch so dann
nehme ich mein glas
an der stelle müsse man vielleicht
einmal sagen wir sagen nicht genau
welches gas ich will hier keine
anleitung heute glück sondern wollen
einfach zeigen wie genau denn da los
sodann in die bogen reinhalten das gas
abfüllen ist schwerer wie luft und es
wird sich also in den tresor unten an so
und dann muss man ein gefühl haben wie
viel zu wenig man kriegt die krise nicht
auf macht dicke backen wenn ich jetzt
aber richtig voll machen dann kann ich
die ganzen das ganze geldinstitut mit
sprengt was ja schon öfter passiert ist
also eine ganz gefährliche sache so
wenig als gas eingeführt habe dann mache
ich eine nasse zündschnur das heißt also
wenn ich jetzt eine mutation schule
einsetzen würde und würde jetzt ein
feuer entfachen dann sind die
aufsteigenden gase können dann durch
zünden also eine große gefahr für
denjenigen der das hier präpariert
wieder einmal ein gesagt das heißt die
explosion kommt zu früh ich stehe ich
gleich noch mit drin in hanau und das
will man ja nicht und dann nehme ich
also hier diesen flüssigen sprengten dem
flüssigen zündschnur sie das da draußen
bist draußen vor dem gebäude
und dann finde ich das einfach an das
feuer läuft dann rein hier rein und
zündet das gasgemisch und dann knallt es
richtig was genau fliegt dann weg ja
also der tresor der löst sich praktisch
richtig auf das erste da die
schwachstelle ist immer die tür die wird
praktisch aus den halterungen
rausgerissen nicht mehrfach verriegelt
wird rausgerissen und die kann dann im
extremfall wie es zum selber mitgemacht
habe 50 mitarbeiter denken also ganz
gefährliche sache ist hat aber es ist
nicht als sowie als wichtiger bombe
hochgeht dann hat man dann die
möglichkeit das geld raus zu nehmen
genau ist das geld das geld ist also mit
hinten von hinten immer gefüttert und
ich kann also hinten diese geldkassette
rausnehmen und in regel verbringt kein
geld dass also die temperaturen reichen
nicht aus weil es ein augenblick der
schock bei der sprengung ist und dann
kann ich das rausnehmen und nehmen wie
lange dauert das was sie gerade
geschildert haben für jemanden der
erfahrung der mit hause unter fünf
minuten unter fünf minuten das längste
ist das vorbereiten dass also die sache
mitzubringen bohren und anzusetzen gas
einzuführen das ist das was am längsten
dauert zwei bis drei minuten so und dann
kommt die sprengung und dann springt er
relativ schnell und dann natürlich das
geld einpacken und zu verschwinden
wahnsinn wie schnell gibt es für eine
bank eine chance sich irgendwie dagegen
zu schützen mechanismen einzuführen um
das zu verhindern natürlich neue geräte
einführen die neuen geräte sind super
gebaut die haben ein gas wanne eingebaut
die neutralisieren das dann auch und
natürlich dann auch wenn es ganz hart
kommt wie das geld noch mal eingefärbt
das ist also das geld mit dann
unbrauchbar ich kann es nicht mehr
umtauschen ich kann mit dem geld nichts
mehr anfangen das wollte sie noch fragen
als laie ja hier gibt es diese riesige
explosion das ding fliegt auseinander
wie kann es dann sein dass dabei das
geld eigentlich nicht kaputt geht die
temperatur reicht nicht aus das heißt
dass gas entwickelt nicht so eine hohe
temperatur dass er verbrennt mit
sprengstoff sieht dass da wieder anders
aus sprengstoff kann noch wesentlich
mehr temperatur freisetzen eben über
2000 grad und da kann man also was
schüler verbrennen sag ich mal die gase
sind augenblicklich da und durch den
verbrennung der gase wird anfang druck
aufgebaut und von innen halten nichts
aus sie tresore dann geht eben auch
kaputt sie haben noch da
plastiksprengstoff mitgebracht jahren
das ja das sind die neuen sachen jetzt
neun tresore neuen geldautomaten die
sind relativ sicher und man versucht die
jetzt also neuerdings mit sprecher von
außen zu sprengen das ärgerliche dabei
ist das natürlich der schaden wie sie
größer ist das also der sprengstoff hat
seine gewalt das ja das ganze gebäude
zerstört hat ist ja schon passiert der
tresor bleibt in der regel heilt
ob sich ganz stark dann kriegt man immer
wieder auf aber das geld bleibt im
tresor er starb in vielen dank dass sie
heute abend bei uns waren danke für ihre
expertise und natürlich hoffen wir dass
die banken sich das was sie gerade
gesagt haben berücksichtigen damit diese
dinger nicht häufiger geknackt werden
können dankeschön